[Music]
and look how cute my girls are at my
home look what they did for me oh my god
my little baby oh my I'm just in love
Khloe Kardashian leaves Ohio with baby
true Thompson in tow this comes after a
source exclusively revealed to eat see
that Chloe was staying in Cleveland to
figure out her future in the wake of
boyfriend Tristan Thompson's alleged
cheating album gotta figure it all out I
promise you at the time our source said
quote Chloe is very torn on what to do
with her interest in adding Chloe loves
him deeply he is the father of her child
but she feels betrayed and blindsided
there's a million different emotions
that are going on in my brain despite
the drama surrounding Tristan's alleged
cheating scandal Chloe's family has
rallied around her with support I've
taught my kids from day one you know
family's everything so that comes first
that same philosophy seems to be
carrying over into Chloe's legacy our
source says her main focus is figuring
out what is best for true after the 33
year old reveals her newborn daughter's
name on social media she proudly gushed
over her baby girl writing in part our
little girl true Thompson has completely
stolen our hearts and we are overwhelmed
with love
[Music]
[Applause]